the Fall From Grace for a once high
profile attorney in the Low Country a
South Carolina judge sentenced Alec
murdaugh to two consecutive life
sentences without the possibility of
parole a day after a jury found the
dispared attorney guilty of all four
counts in the murders of his wife Maggie
and his youngest son Paul Nikki Batiste
was there as murdaugh learned his fate
but I'm innocent I would never
under any circumstances hurt my wife
Maggie and I would never under any
circumstances hurt my son Papa a day
after a jury convicted Alec murdaugh of
double murder judge Clifton Newman did
not mince words well it might not have
been you it might have been the monster
you become the judge sentenced murdal to
life without parole and I know you have
to
see Paul and Maggie during the night
times when you're attempting to go to
sleep
all day and every night
with his surviving sunbuster watching
the disgraced former lawyer was led out
of court in shackles and taken away to
spend the rest of his life Behind Bars
prosecutors portrayed murdal as a serial
liar who shot his wife and son to death
on the night of June 7 2021 to distract
from his drug addiction an alleged
Financial crimes that were about to be
revealed but once I lied I continued to
lie here sir Murdoch repeatedly told
investigators he was visiting his mother
when the crimes were committed but cell
phone evidence placed him at the murder
scene when he took the stand in his own
defense he admitted he'd lied I don't
think I was capable of Reason defense
attorney Jim Griffin he could have had
Mother Teresa up there talking about how
he's changed and
he would have gotten a life sentence
there's no question the murder weapons
were never found and there were no
eyewitnesses yet it took the jury less
than three hours to find murdal guilty
verdict guilty lead prosecutor Creighton
Waters a verdict like this doesn't give
Paul and Maggie their life back but at
least that jury gave them a voice
the defense told me they plan to appeal
the guilty verdict but regardless of
that outcome Murdoch could still face
life in prison for his alleged Financial
crimes some of which he admitted to
during this trial I spoke with two of
Maggie murdaugh's close friends who told
me this verdict is the Justice they'd
been hoping for for CBS Saturday morning
Nikki Batiste Walterboro South Carolina